Amazon board Pepsi and more from Amazon
these are just a few of the companies
that have said they were starting big
layoffs in the last year some job cuts
are expected when the economy hits a
rough patch but this is different not
because of the number of people being
laid off but because of who we're seeing
a really unusual situation where
white-collar workers professionals are
being laid off in greater numbers
relative to the rest of the workforce
here's why white collar jobs are getting
cut first and why that's a departure
from slowdowns in the past
foreign ever since this wave of job Cuts
started last year experts have said that
this downturn could spell trouble for
professional workers this recession is
going to be really bad not only for
white collar workers but white white
Patagonia vested workers but to
understand why those cuts are happening
we have to go back even further to the
beginning of the pandemic as the economy
went into crisis mode layoffs hit a lot
of Industries but ones that are not
predominantly white collar were some of
the most affected entertainment and
Leisure and Retail which hire a lot of
low-wage and Frontline staff made up
most of the job Cuts in the first seven
months of 2020. in-person workplaces
everybody got sent home and so you had a
lot of white-collar workers who could do
the kinds of jobs that companies still
needed in great quantity and companies
like zoom boom companies like Google and
Microsoft suddenly there are products
were in much greater demand as the
economy started to recover some
Industries saw the average number of
employees grow from pre-pandemic levels
While others especially those with
Frontline workers grew only a little bit
or were left at a deficit but as
employers are now making job Cuts amid
Rising interest rates
they're facing two major problems
for some it's an excess of white collar
workers who may have been hired for
special projects or company expansions
during the pandemic some of those
projects have been closed or pulled back
or narrowed and so companies that hired
a lot during the pandemic are just
finding they don't need as many people
but elsewhere there's an unmet demand
for workers namely in Blue Collar low
wage and Frontline jobs it feels like we
have a structural labor shortage out
there where there are you know four
million fewer people a little more than
4 million who were in the workforce
available to work then there's demand
for Workforce the FED says the shortage
has multiple causes some of it is due to
more people going into retirement but
other factors like slowing immigration
are also playing role
some economists also say that mindsets
about work have shifted amid covid-19
for these workers
if we look back at that change in
employees on payroll some of the
industries that have had a harder time
recovering are ones that a lot of
workers didn't return to and companies
don't want to risk being unable to fill
important jobs as the economy speeds up
again so they're being careful about
keeping those workers some people call
it labor hoarding they're actually
holding on to these people trying to
keep them from leaving even if they
don't need them all right now as hiring
has started to slow ads for jobs in
white collar industries have fallen the
most and as for layoffs white collar
workers are there they're paid more so
job Cuts can save you more money with
fewer people and you don't risk giving
up those hard to find Frontline workers
that you're going to need when the
economy improves but this breaks from
the norm of what has happened in many
other economic slowdowns usually First
Capital intensive Industries lay people
off factories and construction companies
then you see companies with large
low-wage workforces retailers
hospitality companies restaurants and
hotels then only later as the economy
really starts to slow and as as a
recession looms or or kicks in our
professional workers and white collar
workers usually laid off just look at
the recession in the early 1980s where
blue collar workers made up 75 percent
of layoffs it's few and far between jobs
are hard to come but how about you you
hiring and even more recently in 2007
just before the start of the Great
Recession blue collar industries like
construction and Manufacturing were some
of the first to start losing jobs by the
end of 2008 when Mass layoffs were
gaining steam industries that are not
predominantly white collar were some
that had the most job cut announcements
that's excluding Finance which was in a
crisis so so the the classic Model we've
seen over the past 30 to 40 years is
that when companies see a Slowdown
coming they shed workers they figure you
know we can always hire them back once
business picks up again but that didn't
happen after the pandemic but even if
white collar workers are mostly affected
by this downturn they don't typically
stay unemployed for long the majority of
tech workers who were laid off this year
landed a new job within three months of
starting their search some smaller
companies are finding it easier to hire
now because you know there's more people
on the market so just because there's a
lot of layoffs doesn't mean no one's
hiring despite the layoffs the job
market remains Strong by historical
standards the FED is still looking for
it to cool further the economists I've
spoken with expect more layoffs they
don't expect it to be like in the
financial crisis when you saw a pretty
widespread layoffs but they do expect
layoffs to spread from you know Tech and
white collar to other areas where the
economy may slow down next some
economists say that layoffs could become
more precisely targeted and
underperformers as companies try to hold
on to their most valuable employees